اختلفت سنه 2022 عن سابقاتها بسرعه
الاحداث وتعدد القرارات الرئاسيه لاستكمال
خريطه الطريق التي وعد بها رئيس التونسي
وقيس سعيد اثر اجراءات استثنائيه للسنه
الماضيه الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي جرت
في السابعه عشر من شهر ديسمبر كانت اخر
حلقه في خريطه الطريق المعلنه غير انها
كانت موضوع نقد وتعليق من المعارضه وهيئات
محليه ودوليه مختصره في مراقبه الانتخابات
لمتسمت به من ضعف في نسبه المشاركه لم
تتجاوز احد 10% وعدده النسبه الاضعفه في
تاريخ الانتخابات في تونس منذ استقلالها
في خمسينيات القرن الماضي
الاجراءات التي اعلنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
خلفت بدورها ردود فعل متباينه بين من
اعتبرها ضروره لاصلاح السياسي ومن راى
فيها تركيزا للحكم الفردي كالاستشاره حول
الدستور والنظام السياسي وحل المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء وعزل اكثر من 50 قاضيا وحل
البرلمان ثم الاستفتاء على الدستور الذي
تلاه اصداره قانون انتخابيا جديد غير نظام
الاقتراع من التصويت على القوائم الحزبيه
الى التصويت على الافراد مع منع التمويل
الحكومي عن المرشحين
الاجراءات الرئاسيه حركه سواكنا المعارضه
والمجتمع المدني فشلنا القضاه اضرابا عن
العمل مشروعا باعتصام واضرابا عن الطعام
لعدد منهم وكثافه المعارضه تحركاتها
الميدانيه مطالبه باسقات ما تسميه
الانقلاب
رفعوا المعارضه لنسق مطالبها قابلته
محاكمات سياسيه امام القضاء العسكري لعدد
من قادتها ولنواب من البرلمان المنحل
وليصحفينا ونشطاء مدنيين مشكله الرئيس قيس
سعيد لم تعد فقط مع اطراف معينه ومع
المعارضه وانما اصبحت مشكله الرئيس بشكل
جوهري واساسي مع المواطنين وخاصه
المواطنين الذين امنوا به واعطوه نوع من
التصوير
ازمه سياسيه ودستوريه تزامنت مع ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه توصف بالعميقه
والخطيره زادتها تازما الاوضاع الاقليميه
والدوليه جراء تداعيات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه فكان انقطاع مواد اساسيه من
الاسواق بين الحين والاخر وغلاء الاسعار
وارتفاعه نسبه التضخم وغيرها من المظاهر
التي دفعت لاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل الى
شاني اضراب عام خلال شهر يونيو حزيران
الماضي للمطالبه بحلول توقفو نزيف الازمه
وتراعي القدره الشرائيه الشغالين مثل ما
يقول الاتحاد
سنه 2022 انه اييي احتدت الازمه خاصه انه
في ظل غياب قرارات شجاعه من السلطه
التنفيذيه لاخذ يعني الاجراءات اللازمه
والتي هي كذلك تصب فيما يطلبه صندوق النقد
الدولي وهذه اجراءات ضروريه سنه تتلوها
اخرى يعتبرها الرئيس قيس سعيد من عرجا
تاريخيا في مقاومه الفساد واسترجاع
الاموال المنهوبه سابقا الى خزينه الدوله
في حين يتوقع الخبراء الاقتصاديون انها
ستكون سيئه لتراجع الانتاج وشح الموارد
الماليه لخزينه الدوله
سامع اليوم وتعتبرها المعارضه سنه الحسن
مع اختلاف في اوساطها بين المطالبين برحيل
ما يعتبرونهم قلبا وبدايه صفحه جديده وبين
المنادينا بحوار وطني شامل ينزع فتيل
الازمه على مختلف الاصعد لطفي حجي الجزيره
تونس